Emma is with us to start off this hour
in Raleigh North Carolina I am a how are
you are you doing better than I deserve
what's up hey dad I've had a question um
my husband and I have been married for
about six months we are on a baby steps
to although I say that tentatively
because it more feels like I'm on baby
step two because my husband um well not
unwilling it's just not at the same kind
of a level of intensity that I would
like for him to be you know we paid off
$12,000 of dad since you've been married
in six months yes sir
good and what's your household income
right now it is about 70 mm-hmm I just
got a new job I'm starting about two
weeks and it's gonna be a $10,000 raise
good for you let it go so yeah really
really excited she'll give me an example
of when he's not intense so um I'm
looking at our debt snowball and I'm
saying you know I really think with my
raise and with this I really think we
can be out of this in a year
you know maybe 80 14 months max if we
just really cut down on everything and I
think that's because especially now
we've paid off at 12,000 really all
these technically obtained minimally
every month is about three hundred and
fifty dollars and I think he's just not
mad enough about it give me an example
of when he's not mad enough sometimes is
there some time you're wanting to do
something in the budget that to cut
something and to show your intensity and
he doesn't want to do it to show his
lack of intensity yeah so like we don't
have a thousand dollars in the emergency
time we have over four thousand dollars
and he would never agree so just
throwing that three thousand after that
we have left why because you want he
wants more security than much do you how
much debt do you have left
we've got 28,000 left
okay you paid off 12 so here's the thing
okay you all are not in agreement as to
the system you're gonna use telling your
money and getting out of debt it's not
his intensity it's you're not in
agreement once you're in agreement that
you're going to do the Dave Ramsey baby
steps then by definition you're doing it
wrong but you've not even started with
that agreement right and so you know
he's still smarter than everybody else
while he's sitting there with his but
28,000 bucks and debt great yeah
and so this isn't an intensity thing
this is an arrogance thing hmm well I
think part of it is to you know he he's
done really well at his job and started
its job making 15 bucks twenty eight
thousand dollars in debt he's broke he's
not good at handling money I don't give
a crap how good he is at his job you
probably about him not doing the debt
snowball with you right what I'm saying
is that I think part of the issue is
that he's never made money before and I
think he's actually also struggling with
finally me no darling no darling there's
not what you called me about the issue
is is that the two of you are not in
agreement that getting out of debt
matters and that you're gonna work this
system right there's a whole myriad of
excuses for not doing anything that you
can come up well I mean you got it but
he's just you know the two of you have
got to decide so here's the thing I I
suspect you said you've been married six
months yes sir and how old are you - I'm
24 23 okay then here's what you do okay
you turn off the television and you
light some candles and you have dinner
and you say darling this is freaking
important to me and if it doesn't become
important to you your life's not going
to be as good because I'm about to
explain to you how this wife stuff works
we're gonna get on the same page out of
a scale of 1 to 10 I understand this is
not a 10 to you but you need to hear me
really loudly this is a 10 to me this
matters that we get on this system and
that we get out of that we are freakin
23 and 24 years old
we don't know squat and so don't sit
over here and tell me about your
financial genius you're twenty-eight
thousand dollars in debt honey and
we are going to do this this is how you
say you do wife stuff okay you just kind
of talk I got to tell you as a guy my we
don't
my wife spent the first seven years of
our life trying to hint things at me and
she gave up hinting things to me I don't
do hints I don't hear hints I don't hear
subtleties you have to hit me in the
face for the two before and then I
understand what you said so you have to
speak really plainly and up in his grill
he does not get your subtleties you
followed me through this
he just had this guy loves you and he
has not heard how important this is to
you that we do this and we do it quickly
and we do it right so that we can live
like no one else and give like no one
else so have you guys got the tote have
you guys got the Total Money Makeover
book yes I do have you been through
Financial Peace University
I have not would he go if you made him I
think he would okay I will give it to
you as my Christmas gift and that will
solve your problem but you have to get
him to go to the class and he has to
hear how important this is to you
darling here's what I want for Christmas
I want you to agree to go this class
it's one that was one of my Christmas
gifts to me okay and I'll give you an
example my wife wants to redecorate the
dining room again I freaking do not
understand this and I mean I I mean I
have no idea how this works why it works
why it matters all I am sure about is
it's important to her that much I got so
guess what
she'll be redecorating the dining room
not because I give a rip I don't give a
rip about the dining room we can sit on
the floor in there as far as Dave's
concerned I'm a pretty easygoing guy
okay but it's important to her so guess
what we're gonna do it because I care
about my wife it matters to her but she
had she can't go you know I don't know
if I like the counter in here you know
what I do if she says that I had to keep
driving I keep walking I don't hear that
but she says this is a big freakin deal
to me this is bothering me I really want
to do this her husband who loves her
suddenly heard her that's all this is
anyway you just hadn't gotten through to
your new husband yet and sometimes
husbands have to be kind of punched in
the face we don't do subtlety thanks for
the call
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]